I never really was one of those kids who
knew exactly what she wanted to do a lot
of people say so have you ought did you
always want to be a fashion person what
you did you dream of being a designer
and I'm like no never
I found a notebook went from when I was
around 12 and I would like draw dresses
and make clothing for paper dolls but
all I really wanted to do was a job that
would make a difference
[Music]
my name is van de guiche guru and I'm
the CEO and co-founder of vivo which is
the ladies fashion brand based in
Nairobi Kenya what's special about us is
that we designed specifically for the
modern African woman so taking into
account our different body shapes and
sizes are different skin tones are
different lifestyles and and style
preferences when I started the business
I struggled because I didn't understand
how it could really translate to making
a difference to to anyone else in parts
of Africa the ready-to-wear clothing
space has been dominated by imports of
product that was never designed for us
the African woman most of the time we
will get our clothes from second hands
or imports from Asia and normally
because they are not made for the
African woman sometimes they can be
unflattering if it fits the top half of
your body might not fit the bottom half
so most people haven't you know known
what it feels like to wear something
that was made with you in mind
and it was the first time that that I
could see that you know building a
significant business in a country like
ours changing the the narrative around
what local product could mean and what a
what difference that could make to
multiple lives in many different ways
I saw that for the first time and I
remember having goosebumps and thinking
oh my god I don't have to try and find
another way to make a difference I can
make a difference right here and I think
it's more than just clothing and style
it's about what makes you feel more
confident appreciated or accepted
right now we employ about 80 people 70%
of which are women I'd like to think
that we are you know it's a good place
to work we try hard no one works more
than a five-day week which in Kenya is
not typical from my previous company it
was very difficult to have work-life
balance because I worked during the
weekends and sometimes even during the
holidays in long hours but with people
they prioritize their employees
work-life balance
we provide meals everyday for everyone
who works for us last year everyone was
on health insurance not yet their
dependents you know so maybe next year
if our company grows enough that would
be the next stage know it seek arise to
one of the hospitals around I get
treated you come back I compare that the
place I was that wasn't there so you can
see able to spend your cash for the
treatments
we're visited by fashion students like
three or four times a year we invested
in computer-aided pattern making
software last year and we had a bunch of
students visit us last month and they
said you know it's so good to see this
because they've been teaching us about
it
for three months but only the theory
like no one has the software so they
just read about it and they watch
youtube videos but they're like we
finally have seen what it actually looks
like yeah we do new things new designs
every day and that is a plus to me yeah
if I compare when I came and two years
now I can say a lot much I want to
believe that we'll vivo products will be
available anywhere in the world that you
wish to have them sourced on the
continent made on the continent but with
a global audience in mind and then I
want to spend a lot of my time trying to
see how to import and motivate and
encourage and inspire the younger
generation of women in business
what drives me for sure and hopefully
the business as a whole is the
opportunity that we have to inspire
women and change the way we see
ourselves
[Music]
you